[Musique]
quarante huit heures après l attaque au
mortier du commissariat de
champigny-sur-marne dans le val-de-marne
les policiers ont manifesté leur colère
et leur album
là on a passé un cap totalement
différent un cap
on a voulu s'en prendre aux hommes avec
une bande organisée avec la une volonté
véritablement de casser du flic
il ya des gens coordonnées des caïds des
voyous qui essayent impressionnait la
république
je suis venu vous dire ce soir je suis
bill dire à tous ceux qui essayent de
tester la république ils gagneront pas
c'est une zone où il ya beaucoup de
circulation d'héroïne nous mettant de
plus en plus notre nez là dedans nous
démantelons des trafics jeu l'a encore
vu à toulouse
évidemment je vous le disais ça ne plaît
pas ça dérange y réagissent et bien ils
peuvent réagir tant qu'ils veulent ils
auront affaire à nous nous serons
intraitables
je souhaite que dans la prochaine
prochain un texte de loi qui arrive à
l'assemblée nationale le 19 novembre la
proposition de loi de monsieur frère gay
même chez rue ne puissions définir comme
une arme à destination c'est le feu
d'artifice ces mortiers
ce sont ces engins pyrotechniques depuis
une loi de 2010 est la vente des
mortiers les plus puissants et réservé
aux professionnels des feux d'artifice
mais on les trouve très facilement sur
internet
c'est un peu comme l'alcool interdit aux
mineurs en réalité si on met pas de
véritables moyens avec un réseau pour
permettre finalement que les artificiers
les vendeurs puissent se retrouver
finalement peut-être mis face à leurs
responsabilités en cas de vente à des à
des particuliers notamment et des
mineurs on fera du blabla pour rien la
question majeure c'est pas de savoir si
on va interdire les feux d'artifice sur
internet
beau courage d'ailleurs eu c'est de
rétablir une chaîne pénale
une chaîne pénal avec des peines
plancher pour les récidivistes avec des
peines planchers pour ceux qui agressent
les forces de l'ordre rappelle quand
même que il existe une force légitime
qui est à la disposition de l'état
bon il faut cesser d'avoir d'avoir
lumineuse
à ce sujet quand un commissariat avec
d'attaqué ben c'est un acte de guerre
civile parce qu'on s'attaque à des
institutions et donc là il faut réagir
ça se passait il 68 vaut mieux une
vitrine cam ans elle n'a pas changé
c'est peut-être aussi le premier acte il
faudra s'en souvenir de ce qui pourrait
devenir dans notre pays une guerre
civile si on ne répond pas immédiatement
l'oubli quand les ordres de maintenir
l'ordre 100 morts et 100 blessés
il faut suivre les eaux avec efficacité
et détermination donc quand on voit des
je ne vois aucun ministre de l'intérieur
qui dira à tirer dans le tas c'est pour
ça que j'ai employé l'image pas pour le
plaisir de faire une métaphore maritime
d'une grande marée quelque chose qui va
doucement elle arrive mais qui arrive et
qui est très large et et comme dans les
grandes marées quelques fois on pense
qu'on a le temps et en fait à la fin il
ya une course contre la montre et on est
à ce moment là dans lequel on s'engage
dans cette course contre la montre la
réalité de la deuxième vague est là et
donc j'appelle j'appelle de façon
extrêmement clair à ce que nous nous
mobilisions toutes et tous pour faire
face à cette deuxième vague ne peut plus
y avoir de relâchement
et puis c'est au tour de toulouse et de
montpellier de basculer dès demain donc
en alerte maximale c'est l'information
de ces dernières heures et derniers
chiffres sans en abuser 17% des tests
reviennent positif c'est un chiffre
qu'on n'avait jamais atteint nous venons
de classe et montpellier et toulouse 1
zone d' alerte maximale
donc il faut voir ce que ça donne dans
ces collectivités pas exclu que
finalement c'est à exclure confinement
locaux monsieur rien ne doit être exclue
il semble que je sois immunisés donc je
peux enfin sortir de ma cachette
ce que j'aurais fait de toute façon est
ce que j'ai fait parce qu'il faut bien
diriger le pays
mais il semble que je sois immunisé pour
je ne sais pas peut-être une longue
période peut être très peu de temps
peut-être pour la vie on ne sait pas
mais je suis immunisé